[Music]
hello how about me ring
with top headlines
for today monday november 9
a las vegas woman is expected to appear
in court tomorrow accused of killing her
own children this happened
friday afternoon near  of turin and maryland
parkway the metropolitan police said
that ame under star saferstein, 26,
killed his two children they were
discovered by their father who called
911 the police did not
immediately release details of this incident
some races in the valley are still
very much fought between  the candidates this
includes senate district 6 and
protector is only 700 votes
behind the cold who
hoops senate district 5 is even
closer
christina was in leads kerry
handbold by 134 votes and in
clark county commission  plasma grass up
by 260 votes before boards have had
construction work underway on new back between
tropicana and believe the project estimated
at 26 million promises to make these
streets safer for drivers
the asphalt is deteriorated in addition to the
need to replace the traffic lights they
also add space for the
disabled they improve the sidewalks
among so many changes drivers
will have two lanes while this
project lasts  but only one between eight
at night and six in the morning from
Sunday to Friday and now we turn to
the weather forecast we will be
reaching 58 degrees with a maximum
despite having a clear day it will be
very cold for tomorrow the
same temperatures are expected  Take off your coat
because the cold has arrived to stay that
I have the daily wine and mine is lightened and
this was your brief disney news
in Spanish
[Music]